hello there we are now at the
penultimate episode of obi-wan kenobi
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down all the easter eggs
hidden details and things you missed i
also want to discuss the series as a
whole and my general reaction to it but
we'll go over that towards the end of
the video heavy spoilers from here on
out so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the episode then check out now
if you enjoy the video pretend i'm the
like button and hit me baby obi one more
time
fake the puns start getting really bad
five episodes in and without the way i
love you now let's get into obi-wan
kenobi okay so last week had obi-wan
launching an attack on fortress
inquisitorius in order to rescue
princess leia vader was that riva for
letting him get away however she had a
new hope in the fact she'd placed a
tracking device aboard the milleni lola
so alola her name was lola she was a
probe droid and now she's giving them a
way to track down the group now we start
off on coruscant with a flash back to
the time of the clone wars without the
bacter tank in the same place that we
saw the younglings training in episode 1
we watch anakin and obi-wan dueling it
out this is back when they were both
mates around the time of attack of the
clones which we can tell due to the
hairstyles that the pair have anakin is
still an apprentice hence the ponytail
and it's one of vader's fondest memories
we actually open by looking at padme's
penthouse and pull out to see anakin
staring at it i'm guessing this takes
place just after they got married and
he's clearly thinking about the
character throughout this episode we get
several flashbacks of it and it shows
anakin's impatience anger and also the
differences between the two the battle
of course holds more meaning now that
they're enemies and it's filled with
lots of foreshadowing to the fights
they'd have later on the combat style is
also more in line with the prequels and
we've seen throughout the show how vader
adopted a different style of fighting in
episode 3 that was more in line with
what he had later on we get two versions
of him and flashbacks throughout the
episode and this is when he's still a
jedi and later on when he becomes a sith
he almost beats rb1 but this episode
shows there are other ways to fight and
anakin actually learns this as we get
further into it he knocks obi-wan's
weapon out of his hand and we also get
this line your weapon's gone
[Music]
it's over
your need for victory anakin it blinds
you
later obi-wan hands over his weapon and
he theorizes that vader will be unable
to see the plan with riva because he's
blinded by his need to win anakin very
much strikes with rage and frustration
and this is a similar thing to what he
did in their battle in episode three
this wailing away is also something that
luke did in return of the jedi when he
completely lost control and it's very
much a pathway to the dark side we could
have the bridge of his star destroyer to
see him gazing out into the galaxy this
is a motif that's popped up several
times in the saga and it's not only
where we last saw him in revenge of the
sith but it's also a stance he took
after beating lucan empire this star
destroyer is devastated class and it's
one of the most iconic ships in the star
wars universe this has appeared a number
of times throughout the saga and the
first time it showed up in the timeline
was during the battle of scarif in rogue
one when vader arrived it later appeared
at the start of a new hope and then at
the beginning of the battle of hoth all
of which were considered victories for
the empire enter eva who informs him
that obi-wan is just arriving on jabim
this was the planet that we saw last
time and it has a number of things that
have happened there in the expanded law
after order 66 this planet became the
final sanctuary for the path and it's
where the four sensitive people who made
it there received new identities it was
also a planet that fell under the
control of the first order and using
wookiee slaves they mined the thing dry
river is told to kneel and she's given
the position of grand inquisitor making
her vader's right hand a bit of a joke
because because it got cut off
looks like things are all falling into
place as she gets to be assistant to the
regional sith lord and we later learn
this is all part of a plan in which
she's actually hunting vader for what he
did on the jedi temple now obi-wan
arrives to find that hajja is now there
and we discover after the end of episode
2 that he became wanted by the empire
broken talks about how the people there
have all been waiting for a transport to
leave and typically those here would be
sent on secret trade routes throughout
the galaxy these were unmonitored by the
empire and they allowed characters like
han solo to carry out smuggling jobs
lola goes into one of the service
tunnels and we saw something similar in
the mandalorian when grogu attempted to
fix the razor crest at the start of the
ahsoka episode the droid ends up sealing
them inside in order to get them to
surrender which is what the main focus
of the episode centers around on the
wall obi-wan sees the names of jedi
along with the crest in the middle this
is of course similar to the underground
railroad one in episode three and
alongside it are some lightsabers now as
we know these are all personally built
by the jedi and i actually went through
a guide of lightsaber handles that have
appeared in the saga and try to match
them up however i couldn't find many
that really lined up except for this one
which belongs to glup shitto just
kidding the second one from the left
actually looks a lot like quinlan vosses
who we know also traveled on the path he
was a rebellious badass jedi that was
name dropped in episode 3 and it does
seem like it belongs to him let me know
below though if you know the others as
well and you know just putting comments
on the video it helps actually push this
one so i'm gonna trick you into doing
one now there's also a robe alongside it
and this brings back memories of the
order to obi-wan beta sends in two
landing shapes and these look like the
precursors to the one from the start of
the force awakens there's several aliens
in the hangar including trend oceans who
put their heads together these are the
same species as bosque and it really
shows the despair they have outside the
stormtroopers arrive with riva and along
with a repeating blaster we can also
catch perch troopers these were actually
the personal forces of the inquisitors
and they were adept soldiers promoted
for their ability to track and kill jedi
they managed to keep it pretty tense
even though it's mostly just them
standing outside the door constantly
shooting for ages like like 20 minutes
now unable to get to the hangar they end
up sending layer into the vents to do a
die hard on her white gown and obi-wan
pulls his hollow projector out of his
pocket this was the tool the jedi often
carried with them alongside their
comlink and he opens it to a message
from bail organa he says he's gonna go
to tatooine to protect the boy and we
get lots of beard stroking lots of beard
stroking from obi-wan this is something
that you and mcgregor adopted throughout
the saga and it's also a gesture he did
at the end of a bench of the sith look
yeah i'll admit the easter eggs they're
pretty sh this episode mate got like
three good ones here so if you want to
go watch the ms marvel video that we did
instead i don't bloody blame you anyway
tala goes to meet him and you might
recognize this room as being where he
recovered in the back to tank last week
she brings up the planet guerrelle a
rocky desert-like one located in the
outer rim as she says this was
controlled by the empire but a rebel
group known as the phoenix cell managed
to rise up there though she doesn't
bring it up per se it is likely that
tala was instrumental in the fractures
of the group starting up because of what
they witnessed the inquisitors
ruthlessly wiped out several families in
front of her in her squadron which cause
dissent we see that she's knocked up
tally marks on her blaster holster which
as we learned is located on the opposite
side of how it's normally wore so that
she's a quicker draw i counted 14 and
this mirrors the fact that she says 14
people died there because of the
inquisitors roe can call somehow and we
see an astromech droid at this point now
this could be r2d2 however we know from
the first episode that he was alongside
c3p on alderaan so i don't know if he
would end up here obi-wan wants to
communicate with riva and he brings up
the point that she knew vader was anakin
which as we theorized means that she met
him during order 66. see kids i told you
it was worth sitting through all those
three times your turn
now anakin arrived hood up like how he
did in revenge of this sith and he
mercilessly cut down the other
younglings in front of her at the start
of episode 1 there were five younglings
so there being just three here shows the
other two are wiped out in the skirmish
in the background we can also catch a
down jedi beside a trooper from the 5.0
first possibly hinting at them dying in
order to protect the kids the 501st was
also the unit that we saw the markings
of on the homeless trooper in episode 2
showing the complete disregard the
imperials had for the clones after order
66 though we only get a split second
shot of one of the younglings getting
cut down i believe that this is the same
one we saw in the tomb last week huge
shout out to jeff hall on twitter for
pointing out this on our last breakdown
and due to them still being in their
training gear they likely would have
been snatched right away after the
attack played out huge shout outs to
ricky kale on instagram for pointing out
there's also this figure in robes and
they do look somewhat similar to
palpatine's assistant janice grigatis
the timeline is off for this with his
appearance being in return of the jedi
but the robes do look very similar so
there is potential that they either come
from the same order or they might be a
relative or something along those lines
it is possible that they're also one of
the witches of dathomir four sensitive
mystics that have acted as both allies
and antagonists in the star wars saga if
you've played fall in order then you'll
remember that they popped up in that and
they were also mentioned in the book of
boba fett as being rancor riders i think
that's the more likely option and it
paints out the picture that this
facility is experimenting on the corpses
of the four sensitive beings here we
know that palpatine was currently in the
process of attempting to clone not only
himself but also snoke so this kind of
lines up now i think this will basically
be the next step up from the cloning
facility on kamino and we'll learn that
this is the place they started trying to
take midichlorians from others so that
they could place them into clone bodies
this was something that the imperials
were seemingly attempting to do with
grogu as well and potentially we'll
learn more about this next week though
don't count on it though cause they've
just been laying the breadcrumbs for
this forever arriva says she thought
anakin was there to help but all he
wanted to do was kill younglings this is
likely where she gained her distrust for
the jedi and she played dead we discover
vader stabbed her in the stomach and she
laid with the other bodies in order to
avoid detection you also learn riva's
true motives and as we talked about on
our earlier video can't remember who
said it exactly but shout out to them
again for saying that riva was trying to
gain a private audience with vader so
that she could kill him and in taking
obi wan to the villain this would gain
his trust she doesn't believe obi-wan
will actually kill him and as we saw in
revenge he left him for dead rather than
finishing the job she blames him for not
helping the younglings and this was also
something we discussed on previous
videos if you cast your mind back to
revenge you'll remember that he and yoda
went to the temple watched the cctv
tapes and obi-wan ended up venturing to
mustafar rather than staying to search
for survivors if he stayed he would have
helped out others and this likely would
have stopped riva going to the imperials
again erie time right eerie time right
theory time right we could we got it
right
now she slices through the blast doors
in a move that's similar to qui-gon
cutting into one in the phantom menace
could have done this way way earlier and
saved everyone some time and it leads to
a big shootout you see that ralking
carries the bell caster and this was
also the preferred weapon of chewbacca
obi-wan breaks out the blocks like i do
when anyone says this video is crap and
they really show stormtroopers can't
shoot for sh because i like i like right
in front of your mate and you're missing
them you're crap italia is shot as is
ned and they cut the sound out and play
emotional music over the top similar to
the ending of rogue one so it feels it
just it just feels emotional now this
reminded me a lot of k2so's death but
she goes the extra mile by setting off a
thermal detonator this was something
leia threatened to do in return of the
jedi and we see the full effects of this
play out whereas jabba and that
de-escalate the situation vader orders
river to stand down as he believes that
obi-wan will do anything to protect the
people and that this includes
surrendering in episode 1 as we saw nori
refused to let others get heard and this
is of course ingrained into the jedi
code obi-wan refused to do this in
episode 1 so he shows he's slowly going
back to his old ways he hands over his
gears and we see that it's all part of
his plan to try and get riva to work
with him in taking down the villain he
pleased to her using the same things
that toller witnessed bringing her
families and sort of doing a kylo ren
and rey and how they took down snoke
leia finds a restraining bolt on lola in
the vans and she ends up removing this
this was something that was also placed
on r2d2 and c3po by the jawas and allows
anyone to basically control the droids
if needs be player opens the hangar
doors the people go to escape and vader
marches in pulling down the transport
through the use of the force this is
something that we've seen at multiple
points in the franchise and not only did
raido and rise of skywalker but we also
saw starkiller do it in the force
awakens to bring down an entire star
destroyer it's a baiting switch like the
show and the real transport manages to
make it out vader was seemingly blinded
by his victory of taking down the
transport that he missed the other one
and it's sort of like poetry they rhyme
however he does suss things out so
perhaps this was part of his own plan to
sniff out riva's true intentions in the
wide shot of the hangar we can also
catch the t47 airspeeders that they used
to launch the rescue mission last week
hyjah also leaves the hollow projector
and we get flashbacks in which obi-wan
beats old anakin because they you can
tell this isn't a 20 year old guys like
how do you do fellow kids what but the
lesson here is important anakin was
constantly trying to prove himself but
this was his undoing riva goes to attack
however he catches the blade using the
force and easily beats her without
bursting out his own blade we see the
quadruple styles of the inquisitor
lightsaber and this includes the single
blade double spinning one and then the
duel vader ends up going toe to toe with
her using the other one and much in the
same way that obi obi-wan beat him by
stealing his blade darth does the same
thing this is probably the standout
scene in the series for me and we get
flashes of her childhood as he walks
towards her the stabbing in her youth is
also the same as what happens here and
she ends up surviving it because
look you should have just killed her
mate now basically it turns out that
obi-wan and riva's theory time was wrong
and we also get the return of the gran
inquisitor who likely told vader the
truth now he is a character that we've
talked and talked and talked about every
week and we did bring up several times
how we thought he was still alive this
was actually somewhat spoiled last week
when rupert's friend who played the
character appeared on jimmy kimmel they
brought up the fact that he got stabbed
in the stomach and friend added that he
only got stabbed in one of them if
you've been watching our videos and
you'll know how we had someone on
twitter called kylo zen reach out to us
to talk about the novel star wars the
last shot this discussed how power and
males had two stomachs and we theorized
that this could be how he survived
eating a balti from ken's super hot
indians down the road from me
available now whenever also calls her
youngling further calling back to her
past in order to belittle her riva finds
the hollow projector and the message
from bail lets her know about tatooine
now she likely feels abandoned by
obi-wan once more and sees this as her
being left to be stabbed so that he can
get away again i do think that it'll go
down on tatooine next week but i think
when she discovers that he's protecting
a child that she will see she had the
wrong impression of him and that she was
just in the wrong place at the wrong
time judging by obi-wan's expression at
the end it seems like he's surprised the
plan didn't work and he knew he'd be a
banning riva to go toe-to-toe with vader
makes it seem like he didn't really care
about her and this is why the ending is
so worrying as she likely wants revenge
pretty solid episode i must say i love
the last 10 minutes and watching vader
just go all out crazy it's always great
to see however i do feel like they're
just dragging their heels a bit with it
i know they have that great lightsaber
fight the character and story
progression feels a bit lacking to me
now don't go don't go hating on heavy
spoilers yeah i just feel like there's
some head scratching character decisions
and you know it's not awful or even bad
i just don't feel it's really elevating
or setting a high standard across the
show and there probably are more misses
than hits for me if we're talking about
things in general now as i said this
episode had some brilliant moments in it
and i feel that the show is at its
strongest when it's focusing on the
relationship between anakin and obi-wan
these two characters being former
friends that are now at opposite ends of
the spectrum for me is the most
interesting thing and whenever we get
introspective moments about their past
that lines up with the present it always
just kind of elevates the show in my
opinion i feel like episodes like this
should have been more common throughout
the series and it's always nice seeing
them kind of go toe-to-toe both mentally
strategically and just doing whatever
they can to try and beat the other now
as i said this did have some good
moments in it love the flashbacks and
the fight at the end but it did kind of
meander getting to those moments and i
don't know if i feel a bit meh on it but
i'm definitely not on the high that i
was at the end of episode three so yeah
i do feel a bit mixed on it but but
there's definitely scenes in this that i
will revisit i just don't feel it is
crazy the best star wars ever like i'm
seeing the reaction being on twitter so
hate all you want but i don't give a now
that's my thoughts on the episode and
for the next part of the video i thought
i'd go over my general feelings of the
series
i did a big twitter thread about this
last week and i think my main issue of
the disney shows in general is that most
of them are written like six hour movies
rather than what they are which is of
course a tv show the six hour movie
thing is something you hear constantly
popping up whenever they talk in
interviews i think it has both its pros
and cons now the majority of tv shows in
general tend to have an almost sort of
self-contained episode feeling where
there's a little mini adventure with
characters and then you might get
something at the end that teases towards
the greater plot this is seen in things
like rick and morty star trek well well
the earlier stuff quantum leap x-files
agents of shield the mandalorian heroes
and so on and so forth this isn't across
the board obviously but on the whole
this is a format that writers tend to
adopt now these long form movie formats
for shows often work but they tend to
bring in a lot of characters so that
things don't get stale you see this in
stuff like stranger things where it
feels very cinematic and it isn't
exactly standalone but you have so many
characters in it that it doesn't get
boring i think the main issue i have
with obi-wan is that we have the layer
rescue mission but it's being dragged
out for hours and hours and hours with
very few characters so it feels a bit
unnecessary remember this is pretty much
the exact same storyline as a new hope
but that had way more going on in way
less time when coming into the show i
thought it would be a sort of adventures
of obi-wan type thing where he'd be on
tatooine maybe he'd come across a
character that was down on their luck
help them out and pop back to luke to
make sure he's okay this is a format we
saw in the comics and it allowed obi-wan
to have run-ins with black resenting
jabba the hutt and many of the big names
that exist on the planet maybe you had
the wrong expectations for it but i
thought we'd get an almost incredible
hulk type of show where obi-wan would
wander into town he'd help someone out
this would make him bust out a
lightsaber it would alert the empire and
then he'd have to flee before vader
showed up again this is all just my
opinion but with there being rumors that
we're getting a second season i hope
they go that route instead of the way
they are with these six hour long
simplistic stories i am still enjoying
the series but i just think that they
should maybe do a longer one where we
have eight to ten episodes with more
self-contained stories rather than what
we have i know it's super difficult for
lucasfilm as well as they have so many
toxic opinions to deal with too so it's
probably difficult for them to actually
figure out what critiques to listen to
and what ones to ignore anyway that's
our thoughts and all the easter eggs we
could find in this episode i'd love to
hear your thoughts on it if you agree
with what i'm saying if you disagree and
like this this six hour thing then
comment below let me know i really don't
mind you can disagree what you want it's
fine as a thank you for that yeah you'll
be entered into a competition where
we're giving away three copies of
everything everywhere all at once on the
15th of july just don't tell those
people that disagree with me they've got
no chance of winning
i'm just kidding yeah and all you have
to do to be with the chance of getting
it is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we pick the comments at
random a month from now and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so message me at heavy spoilers if
that's you if you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out
breakdown of ms marvel which will be
linked on screen right now we've gone
over the most recent episode so
definitely go head over there right
after this without the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you next time take care
peace